from thursday until the start of
december
you must stay at home you may only leave
home for specific reasons
including the education for work let's
say if you cannot
work from home for exercise and
recreation outdoors with your
household or on your own with one person
from another household
for medical reasons appointments and to
escape
injury or or harm to shop for food and
essentials
and to provide care for vulnerable
people or as a volunteer
i'm afraid non-essential shops leisure
and entertainment venues will all be
closed
though click and collect services can
continue and
essential shops will remain open so
there's no need
to stock up pubs bars
restaurants must close except for
takeaway
and delivery services workplaces
should stay open where people can't work
from home for example
in the construction and manufacturing
sectors
single adult households can still form
exclusive support bubbles with
one other household and children will
still be able to move between homes
if their parents are separated if
you're clinically vulnerable or over the
age of 60 you should be especially
careful to follow the rules
and minimize your contacts with others i
know how tough
shielding was and we will not ask people
to shield again
again in the same way but we are asking
those who are clinically extremely
vulnerable
to minimize their contact with others
and not to go to work if they're unable
to work
from home i'm under no illusions about
how difficult this will be for
businesses which have
already had to endure such hardship this
year and i'm truly truly sorry
for that and that's why we're going to
extend
the furlough system through november
the furlough scheme was a success in the
spring it supported people in businesses
in a critical time we will not
end it we will extend furlough until
december